foreign
[Music]
hey you guys time once again for tomes
of Terror my little book review series
now today we're going to be talking
about
um the award-winning author Brian Smith
now from what I could gather because
this is the first thing of his that I've
read
um he's actually more known for his kind
of more splatter Punk or more extreme
works but this particular Novella I
guess it kind of counts as a novella
because it's fairly short
which came out in 2021 is called the
Unseen and although this one definitely
has kind of some slasher type Gore in it
it's actually kind of more character
focused and it has an absolutely great
premise which I had a really a lot of
fun with
um also I have to give a shout out I
don't usually do this and I probably
should um more often because I'm a
graphic designer so I know how this kind
of stuff goes but I wanted to give a
shout out to the guy that designed the
cover Scott Cole uh because that really
awesome like retro VHS look was actually
a big factor in why I chose this book
out of all of the Kindle unlimited uh
stuff that was offered to me like on the
recommendations so big heads up there
like I said I probably should do that
more often you know what I mean shout
out my fellow graphic designers if they
do like a really really cool cover
design and this one has a really cool
cover design so at the beginning of the
story we meet uh this young woman named
Allison cook who's kind of like this
abrasive uh woman and she's the world's
biggest fan of the Friday the 13th movie
franchise
now as the tale opens she's at a horror
convention and she's kind of like
momentarily stepped outside of the venue
like to have a smoke
now she immediately spots this kind of
tall good looking man uh wearing a
Suspiria shirt and he's pretty openly
like staring back at her
now normally she would be creeped out by
this kind of thing as most women would
be but Alison she's kind of feeling a
little Wicked you know what I mean she's
a little bit like stepping out of her
comfort zone I kind of feel like you
know she's a big horror fan and she has
to be kind of like normal in her regular
work a day life and so when she goes to
horicons she really kind of likes to
bust out and like let her hair down like
she only smokes at horicons and stuff
like that
um so you know she kind of just wants to
be herself like for a little while
so she pretty much marches straight up
to this guy and asks what his deal is uh
vis-a-vis all of the very obvious I
[ __ ] so this guy uh is pretty taken
aback by her forthrightness at first but
uh he does manage to recover his a plum
fairly quickly uh we look as we learn
kind of in the sections because it kind
of goes back and forth between him and
her uh as far as POV goes so in the
sections where we're in his own head we
actually don't find out his real name
until much later in the story but it's
Mark so that's what I'm gonna call him
um he's very aware of how attractive he
is and he doesn't have a hard time like
uh you know pulling trim getting women
but he has a hard time getting them to
hang around for reasons that become
clear as The Story Goes On basically
like Allison is very clearly
wanting to ride the D and so they kind
of have some acerbic back and forth uh
he kind of like I feel like he like nags
her a little bit like you're not the
world's biggest fan of Friday the 13th
he's always kind of like trying to test
her like he's because she's a girl and
she couldn't possibly know all that much
about the series but she absolutely like
you know passes every single test he
thinks to throw at her uh one of which
which I thought was very funny
was that he tells her initially that his
name is Steve minor and she's like
[ __ ] give me some I.T now it's like
if you didn't know anything about Friday
the 13th that wouldn't mean anything to
you but um I mean they do kind of
explain it later on but I immediately
like laughed because I was just kind of
like Steve minor was the guy that
directed the first uh Friday the 13th
and the second one too if I'm
remembering correctly but yeah she
twigged onto that right immediately and
she's like that's not your real name
[ __ ] I want to see like your
driver's license uh so so he then
reveals to her like when it becomes
clear that they're having a little
flirtation kind of moment there uh he's
like I have something very very special
that I as he's like I shouldn't be
showing it to you but since you're so
into it like maybe I should
um and it has to do with her you know
beloved Friday the 13th slasher series
now obviously she doesn't buy this
initially I'm thinking he's just trying
to impress her like get in her pants but
she's just kind of like well I kind of
do want her to get in my pants anyway so
um yeah I'll come back with you like to
your hotel room like against her better
judgment I guess like I said it's not a
good idea like to do but you know she
does actually have two other friends uh
Cassie and Julia who came with her to
the con and they're just like by the
pool or whatever so she like takes a
picture of the guy and says what his
name what his uh room number is and
everything like that and it's like hey
you know this is the guy so if anything
like goes sideways then you know who he
is and where he is so you can like help
me out so they go to his room and have
like really amazing mind-blowing sex or
whatever and then he shows her this very
special thing
now the very special thing is
essentially a Friday the 13th movie that
should not exist it is in fact titled
Friday the 13th nine homecoming
and not only is it [ __ ] great one of
the best films in this in the whole
franchise but it looks exactly like a
movie that was made like in the late
1980s early 1990s complete with the
score by uh Harry manfredini uh Special
Effects by Tom savini himself or at
least that's what it says in the credits
um Allison is like skeptical at first
like when they first start watching it
and she thinks well this is either just
like a really good fan film or like a
really good deep fake but as she watches
it she starts to become convinced that
this is absolutely real
she can't figure out how this could be
though
um as everyone knows the ninth movie in
the Friday the 13th series was Jason
Goes to Hell the final Friday so she's
like where the [ __ ] did this movie come
from uh and is it really as authentic as
it appears to be like there doesn't
she's like look I'm the world's biggest
Friday the 13th fan if this movie
existed and was lost somehow like I
totally would have known about it it
would have turned up on the internet
somewhere and it absolutely has not so
on a whim she decides to swipe the old
VHS tape from Mark's hotel room while
he's in the can she's not initially sure
why she does it she just knows that she
has to have it and uh you know she
doesn't have any particular love for
this guy she just wanted to bang him and
she's just kind of like whatever so she
just like takes it out of the old VHS
that he brought uh the VHS player and uh
so and she just like takes it she wants
to find out if it's real and where it
came from now obviously she knows that
Mark is going to be gunning for her for
the rest because I think this is only
like the first day of the con there's
like two more days so yeah she's like
he's gonna be trying to find me because
I stole it so with the help of her
friends she's basically like I need to
get out of this Con early and go home so
she actually is manages to slip out
um you know her friends kind of like
monitor where the guy is like after she
leaves and she drives the eight hours
back to her hometown without Mark seeing
her one slight problem though and I
don't think this is necessarily a
spoiler because I think that it refers
to this like in the synopsis that's on
Amazon and Goodreads it turns out that
this movie homecoming is a real Friday
the 13th movie but it's one that comes
from another reality like an alternate
dimension
Mark actually received it as a gift from
some kind of like scary like
interdimensional being that he just
calls the visitor
but uh also unfortunately this being's
gifts come with a very very steep price
so the rest of the story is basically
following Mark as he goes on a bit of a
rampage let's call it that uh trying to
find Allison and trying to get the tape
back and that's like intercut with
Allison and her two friends having their
lives really violently upended by the
corrupting influence of this cursed VHS
tape which actually like gets like its
effects get more and more like nefarious
like the farther away it gets from its
original Source like the person that it
was gifted to in the first place so this
is kind of like a really fast-paced
mashup of the Ring I guess because of
the cursed videotape angle that kind of
like has Ripple effects like outside of
it with a Friday the 13th movie
um so this book is like a really really
fun Lively like entertaining story with
kind of like a slasher movie sensibility
there's a lot of slasher type stuff in
it but kind of slightly filtered through
this interdimensional like Supernatural
kind of lens now I will say the
characters are pretty uniformly
unlikable and not all that developed but
the concept is really so fun that it
really hardly matters like I wasn't
really bothered by that all that much
and the book is so short like it's only
160 pages long that it's kind of more
like this breathtaking Sprint to the
Finish like rather than like a longer
like Slow Burn kind of marathon now in
some ways I thought that the briefness
of It kind of like strengthened the
story because it didn't wear out its
welcome on the other hand I think I
maybe might have liked to spend a little
more time getting to know the characters
and a bit more time like on the whole
idea of the visitor because it's pretty
sketchy like sketchally laid out like
where it came from and what its deal is
and stuff like that and how it
influences the world but then on the
other other hand maybe you know I'm
always like a big advocate of like
horror being better when it's like not
explained all that much so maybe now
that I'm thinking about it it was
probably better to like leave the whole
concept of the visitor like you know as
sketchy as it was like the backstory and
the explanations of where it came from
and stuff like that maybe it was just
like better like that because it was
more mysterious so I don't know your
mileage may vary on that kind of thing
but it is just keep in mind it is a very
very short story and um you know this
the characters are while we're inside
Allison's head and inside Mark's head
um you don't really get to know them and
they're kind of unlikable they're both
kind of like jerks you know what I mean
so if that's going to bother you then
maybe it didn't bother me though like I
still thought it was like really fun and
the concept is just so [ __ ] great so
if you're a big fan of 80 slashers in
particular uh I think you'll really get
a kick out of this book because it has
lots of amusing little references and
in-jokes for you know horror nerds and
stuff like that like myself uh it's
somewhat gory and has like a couple of
Fairly graphics vaccines I guess but
nothing as Extreme as Brian Smith's
usual stuff at least as far as I could
gather from like other reviews of like
people that you know were big fans of
his work and read this when they're like
oh this one's really good but it's not
like as extreme or gory it does have a
lot of Gore in it like people getting
chopped up with machetes and stuff like
that people getting horribly uh shot and
[ __ ] like that so it does have some gore
and violence but not as much as he would
usually have but it's a pretty fun ride
though I'll be at a very brief one I
mean I just read it in an hour or two
um and you know to be honest I think
I've said before like I'm always down
for a story about like a curse movie or
a cursed videotape I really really like
that Trope uh so this was like a
definite win for me I had a good time
with it and you know like I said it's
available to read for free on Kindle
unlimited it's very short you can
probably get through it like in an
afternoon and it's a lot of fun if
you're really into slashers so that'll
do it for this installment of tomes of
Terror and I will see you guys again on
the next one bye